changed the world my former student
David you and I have been very concerned
about violence in school and we realized
that students beliefs play an important
role in this what we learned was that
some students believe that people are
just fixed if you're a bully you'll
always be a bully if you're a victim
you'll always be a victim so when
they're excluded or bullied they they
feel that's a bad person I hate them I
feel like a loser I'm ashamed of myself
and they desire violent retaliation but
when they believe people can change when
they believe people have all kinds of
motivations they're not good or bad they
have they're insecure or they have these
needs but those can change they react in
a much less of aggressive way they
understand that a bully might not always
be a bully a victim might not always be
a victim and so their response is so
much more adaptive recently we David
Jaeger and I created a training program
that taught students this growth mindset
this idea that people have thoughts and
feelings the thoughts and feelings live
in their brain and can change and we
showed lowered aggression in the
laboratory and in the classroom these
were high school students the teacher
said why are you working with these
students they cannot change so the
teachers had a fixed mindset about the
students and yet when we addressed the
beliefs that they had that the students
had
what happens is that a lot of students
start believing that there are these
fixed types of people but when they
learn a growth mindset they understand
that no one's fixed everyone has the
potential for change and somehow it
makes them react to exclusion bullying
aggression with much less retaliation
first we brought them into a situation
where they were excluded and they had
the opportunity to retaliate against the
excluder we show that kids who had the
growth mindset intervention were 40%
less likely to retaliate and two to
three times as likely to engage in
pro-social behavior their teachers
reported much improved conduct in the
classroom the their attendance in school
was better and their suspensions were
way down the problem in high school gets
worse people are sifting social groups
everyone's vying for status social
labels are flying around and being put
on everyone so kids are really uptight
and if you add to this the idea that
they might be a fixed person who's
always going to be picked on are always
gonna be a a loser then these
conflagrations begin we had a group in
our study that was taught coping skills
it didn't help them deal with aggression
they were they retaliated just as much
they felt just as bad they showed no
improvement in conduct in the classroom
they did report fewer depressives
but it didn't help them cope socially
whereas changing their beliefs their
mindsets about whether people can change
had an across-the-board positive effect
so we thought why not go to the mother
of all conflicts the Middle East and
what we found with Jewish Israeli is
Palestinian Israelis Palestinians in the
West Bank was that the more they had
this growth mindset the idea that groups
did not have a fixed or evil nature but
could change the more positive were
their attitudes about their adversary
and the more they were willing to make
compromises for peace we're very excited
about these findings and we're hoping
first to refine these interventions so
that we can see longer-term change and
more widespread change I grew up in an
era that had very much a fixed mindset
in my sixth grade class we were seated
around the room in IQ order and so I
asked people to think about this how do
we want the current era to be remembered
do we want to be remembered as people
who measured each other and sorted each
other into categories or do we want to
be remembered as people as scientists
who understood people and understood how
to help them fulfill their potential
chase why under lives change
organizations change the world